des conditions idéales pour démarrer
cette semaine nautique depuis des jours
déjà le vent est soutenu et devrait même
forcir au fur et à mesure des manches
de quoi annoncer des régates physique et
entretenir auprès de nombreux visiteurs
et des délégations étrangères
la réputation du plan d'eau de schelcher
un plan d'eau jugée imprévisible
le plan de la chaîne cherche un peu un
plan d'eau qui est très très tactique et
technique
et vous savez bien que avec
l'urbanisation qui se fait acquis du
côté de celle cher le vent tourner
normalement
donc tant que vous n'avez pas fait
couper votre ligne d'arrivée vous n'êtes
pas promené sur l'eau ce sont les seuls
fish qui inaugure les premiers départs
seulement quatre inscrits cette année
mais avec de vieux briscards à la barre
à l'opposé les plus jeunes et les plus
nombreux cinquante optimiste et déjà des
sens tactique qui se repère et des duels
à surveiller un meilleur départ pour le
jeune rochelais thomas jane it or qui
profitent des ados nantes plus à la cote
pour s'emparer de la tête de course
venu dans thillois théodore spencer a
failli lui voler la vedette
mais ce ne sera pas pour cette manche
on a navigué bord à bord pendant toute
la manche et sur le dernier bord j'ai
réussi à passer devant lui mais
qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence
bah je suis allé en endroit où il y
avait un peu plus de vent du coup je
suis allé plus vite que lui
et lorsqu'on l'a viré je suis passé
devant avec douze coureurs engagés la
délégation antigua et l'équipe étrangère
la plus représentée organisatrice des
prochains championnats du monde au petit
mist en juillet 2019
elle peaufine sa préparation la première
fille se classe parmi les cinq premiers
de la manche
2010 sera une telle mesure aussi à mes
choix est qu elle j'ai gagné quelles ont
été vos principales difficultés des
éclopés sa lettre rappelle d écoper pour
la jeune équipe de france schelcher est
aussi un terrain d'entraînement idéal en
plein hiver hexagonal et avec des
conditions et une adversité de qualité
nous mesurer à nos petits collègues de
la guadeloupe et de la martinique on n'a
pas souvent l'occasion de rencontrer ils
sont bons dans le vent donc nous on a
plutôt un petit déficit dans le monde
donc c'est bien de se mesurer à eux
parce qu'ils vont assez vite sonné
gabarit un petit peu musclé donc ça va
vite donc ça nous et à l'onu si ça nous
permet de savoir si on est dans le bon
rythme il ce rythme il faudra le garder
d'autant que la dernière journée de
mardi s'annonce encore plus ventée